[Music]
the screen junkies show with how running
doctor called turns out it's viral both
my rash and our last episode of screen
junkies christopher walken talking honey
boo boo turned out to be internet crack
and today show crack despite natalie
morales inability to read and check out
this pop culture collision on the film
junkie show it's screen junkies it's
written right next to you with all this
attention i couldn't be more internet
famous unless i was high-fiving hulk
hogan in the middle of his sex tape
since we try to be fair and balanced
here on screen junkies we reached out to
tlc to find out mama and honey's
perspective on this new walk-in boo-boo
feud so slam down your go-go juice
because here comes a honey boo boo child
exclusive
so i'm really excited to be here with
june and alana
can i call you mama yeah that's fine
mama june or coupon queen like a lot of
other people call me alana uh should i
call you honey boo-boo
honey boo-boo child awesome awesome in
england they have the royal family
in america
now i wouldn't say that we're just
everything
did you uh see the video
that you've done yes that was hilarious
women that are a voluptuous size not all
that black jiggle jaggle
jack
so i'm thinking we flipped the script
and have you read christopher walken
lines oh god so okay i've never i've
never seen what is material but yeah we
can try that's okay balls of fury oh
kentucky on a chunky okey dokey out of
toki
that was amazing catch me if you can two
little mice two little minutes
two little mice two little miles two
little mice two mice fell on a bucket of
cream the first mouse drowned drowned
true romance i'm cecilian my father was
the world heavyweight champion of
sicilian liars from growing up with him
i learned the pantomime
what the hell tell me before i do some
damage that you won't walk away from
you're a cantaloupe no you the
cantaloupe baby
[Laughter]
this much was on your dead wrist and it
was shot down on that hand away anyway
he knew that if they ever saw the watch
they confiscated take it away
the waiter then looked at it
was your
birthday first right
i'll say that mama so he hit it in one
place he knew he could hide something
where do you hide it for two years maybe
it was unknown got any idea
he was like come to water
yeah then
he died dysentery
i'm not all about them big financial
awards
then after seven years i was sent home
to my family and now
i give this watch to you
i still want nothing comfortable
you don't want to know you don't want to
know mama i got a prescription and the
only thing to do is get some more
cowbell
let me see how sassy i can be with it
guess what
i've got a fever and the only
prescription
is this cowbell what is a cowboy gonna
do for my headache don't make my egg
worse i gotta have more cowbell cowbell
i put my pants on one leg at a time
except once my pants are on i make gold
raggers
i like what i'm hearing
nice is there any way now that you're
here in california
you would consider going out with him no
oh yes darling don't tell sugar brother
mama can i have a nickname no take oh oh
pop quiet you're a crybaby because i'm
honey booby time that's how it works
honey
mama june honey boo boo
thank you so much for being here today
thank you thank you thank you for having
me
oh mama was making them eyes at me y'all
saw it i'll help you clip them coupons
text me in all seriousness thanks to tlc
for helping us to create this little
piece of internet magic if you like this
week's episode pass it around like it's
a picture of your boss with his shirt
off and let us know what you want to see
the premiere of walking dead was pretty
good but come on less zombies and more
talking about feelings you see the new
carry trailer it's cool to see chloe
moretz branching out to play an oddball
kid who murders people
that's about it i'm hal rudnick bye-bye
honey boo boo child maybe we could turn
this into a honey boo boo motion picture
if you wouldn't mind reading honey boo
boo there are some broke down people out
there please women that are a voluptuous
size not all that bag jiggle jaggerless